hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to osiris new dawn now to be
perfectly honest i don't know a lot
about this game i didn't even know about
it until today when i saw that it was
just released so it seems to be a space
game and i love space so it's early
access which means that it's not fully
done so I'm gonna play it try to learn
about it without being too stupid thanks
for agreeing with me mr. scientist guy I
wish I could be engineer but that's
currently unavailable Outlanders are you
any well Outlanders are red so I guess
that's gonna be me yeah yeah yeah good
enough alright mark you knew uh mark
mark
Cooper Marky booper all right create
planet Proteus two single players
perfect practice and learning your
characters tools and abilities before
jumping into live universe your
character in progress oh by the way this
game is multiplayer so I don't know how
this is gonna go I don't even know if
I'm able to play multiplayer because I
don't know if it's ready yet but I'm
gonna try it out I will try it I'm gonna
try single-player first because I don't
want to be stupid and make everyone mad
at me but then I will be trying
multiplayer to see if there's someone
out there that'll put up with my
stupidity probably not knowing my luck
oh this is a slow there goes universe oh
ah Yee uh okay we're all loaded let's go
Oh third moon of theseus prime are we
doing suit breach oh I'm gonna die oh
what's that
is that a robotic buddy oh I'm gonna die
it's awesome I love space you know some
people ask me why I don't like the ocean
but I love space it's because if I go in
the ocean I know I'm gonna die but if I
go into space I might die so you know
it's pretty cool you know pretty cool
hey how's it going little bubble but for
you bubble Don flank right stroll and
repair
is it oh I don't know what I'm doing
it's at Target huh that box go get it
don't push me bubble but we think you're
doing it oh you're cute I like you very
attentive - yeah I know it's a pretty
cool box huh
okay open survival kit oh that's
convoluted okay structures or phrasing
okay habitat ooh okay so I can build the
habitat but I need resources and
together I have a big Dano I'm
channeling my inner Matt Damon is steam
carrot water bandits med kit multi-tool
chisel patch tape map okay that's good
okay so I need critical breach that
doesn't sound good
I need resources huh good I don't know
I'm gonna die I got a critical brute Oh
patch tape I should probably do that
hey hell yeah Oh two's going back up I
know how to use duct tape person to you
very mass effect II know I kind of like
this whoo that's a little less jarring
than first person okay tool mode yeah I
yeah I'm a tool all right let me go
smash my tool against this rock and
maybe I'll get something out of this
Emel docks I don't know where there's
gonna be an ammo box how do I get this
resource trying to smack my tulip on it
but it don't seem to work nope that oh
man it's a separate thing Oh
so if I go to four ah so somewhere
around here there's an Amur box ooh
build beacons dad more interest points
that sounds so cool I don't know how to
do it
I'm going back oh I like this mode this
gives a much more grand sense of scale
because it puts a point of reference
it's like a banana you put it on your
screen for scale and then you know how
big the universe is all is cool
there's the ammo box I found it it's
Mission Control proud of me no oh that's
why you abandoned me on this desolate
planet oh I crashed but you hoped I
would survive right hmm open ammo box
what do we got
Oh okay so we've got an assault rifle so
I I don't need the patch tape anymore
because I seem to be okay that's not
what my character looked like it's all
my character looked like at all but I
got an assault rifle and I got magazines
which means that I can kill some which
is something that I want to do a lot
okay inflatable dome kit oh okay oh
these are new things that are dropping
okay one inflatable dome kit added to
backpack okay oh oh let's hustle we
gotta build a dome I think I should
probably build the dome closer to over
here let me just tell my little bubble
butt buddy there you go follow me pull
me come with me follow me go for an
early access game which I don't think
it's made by a big-name studio this
might be I don't know the history of the
studio but I don't know who made it it
works out pretty well like the
animations are very fluid the
environment is really detailed the the
scale of it is really impressive I mean
considering that I can see other planets
here and I can see that big planted on
the horizon and I know I'm the third
moon of that planet over there
hot son of a [ __ ] so we got iron and
aluminum right here so what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to you put the inflatable
dome kit build oh that's cool oh that's
so cool oh I love that I love that okay
so it's good enough for me
heavy nope hold action button longer to
build more health why I would want to
build it with as much health as possible
object built at 100% oh it's got a ramp
it's handicap accessible that's good
okay I've got a futon I've got a futon
yes oh I love it okay I was trying to
hold it all my excitement because I
didn't know this game was gonna be good
or not it oh I love it yeah okay so now
that we got that hello hmm oh it
automatically goes the third person as
soon as I get outside okay bubble but
you need to patrol since you can survive
this horrific dust storm over over there
okay search for minerals to build a
forge
you got it buck oh man my suit is
getting dirty which is really nice
detail dad did this game I gotta say who
can't see oh my god this space is so big
oh is that a store up there I hope so
Lily
Lulu Lulu now we got ayran how do I get
it
tool mode missions M search the planet
for the right materials to start
building a Forex utility the forge is an
outdoor crafting table that can be used
to hold woodland by the complex
materials that are needed to expand your
base some more useful and fortified
settlements navigate to the utilities
tab inside the character menu to build
view the build requirements okay
utilities we need a forge so I need this
stuff but I need to know how to get it
maybe the chisel oh of course it's the
chisel Oh get some Oh give some I don't
know I'm holding it like a weapon yeah
get out of here with your pants and what
is that oh that's so cool oh I know I'm
being excited by a shadow but shut up
it's cool oh it's a shadow that mount
it's not just a skybox it's actually a
thing oh that's good detail oh my god I
love attention to detail like that
that's cool that's legitimately cool I
am a hundred percent on board with that
Vivian got ya okay so now I need some
aluminium with my chisel boink - plonk
what's floating in mid-air Oh No
Bambi - boom - BAM - boom okay we get
more iron man's getting hard see in the
shadow of the mountain I love my combat
stance by the way really nice hit me
muskie him oh it encumbered encumbered
and crumb bird okay I guess I didn't
need this much iron so I'll split it and
then drop the bigger step okay I'm good
all right coming back hopefully I can
build a thing now I don't know if that's
gonna be true hey mother but you doing
okay over there oh man I'm so happy that
they gave me my own personal bubble butt
okay so now we need to build a utility
ah [ __ ]
plutonium and titanium where the heck am
I gonna get those can I build a beacon
or something new can I build furniture
though posit Ori okay I can make I can
make a depository oh good I can make a
box oh I can put a box on the ground to
put more of my crap in
so I'm gonna put this depository really
close by to this thing but not too close
apparently it doesn't like that point
nope got about the right thing
mm-hmm
what would be the benefit of not
building something with maximum
integrity I guess if you wanted it to be
temporary and then not be there forever
store store store I don't need all of my
ammo I don't think anyway store
I don't need patch tape yet okay your
vitals are already stable I know store
cannot be removed from ember oh yeah I
should probably have that on my person
at all times I'm the idiot who thought
who's gonna need this in the desolate
wasteland of this alien planet of mine
I'm probably not gonna get another suit
breach I need a whole flashlight battery
I have a flashlight no that's that's not
okay so flashlight there's nothing okay
do I not have a flashlight nurse right
oh it is dark and desolate is this night
now I didn't think that it was gonna be
full night I think it's is overcast
today why what is that what the hell was
that what are you kidding me what the
hell is that it didn't even make a sound
it's just suddenly a fireball keep
shooting after me was that we're not
we're all and we're not gonna talk about
that house is nothing then okay fine
then it's hard to see anything so I can
just go get more irenna yeah what did
I've asked you where's there any
plutonium just sitting around on these
hills soup soup breach suit bridge what
happened did I hit a thorn bush can't
use okay oh it is a thorn bush well I
know how to play two games with one
stone that [ __ ] maybe I wasn't able give
me your alamin give me your alimony
marry me and then let me divorce you
hi girl I'm gonna get you eventually Oh
got it okay got you ha now all my
aluminium ruled to the bottom of the
hill you you you you a my encumbered yet
no I still can carry more okay more
aluminium this hob hob okay okay how's
that got that got that okay whoa that
looks cool
okay Eddie back I need to put some
lights on that sumbitch what if I can
build lights I can probably build lights
suit temperature hi
what can I do about that I'm just so hot
store store actually let me pull some of
this cuz if I build I built an
inflatable dome but that was just
because I had the materials beforehand
so I doubt it's gonna give me anything
but I need a forge which means I need
titanium man there's no lights beacon
that might do it
chemistry table yeah I don't have
anything for that climate controller
holy [ __ ] computer desk that'd be nice
to look up all my porn better than a
futon I suppose but I don't have any
rubber so I just I just need to go out
and get titanium plutonium I need to
stop being such a little [ __ ] and get
this [ __ ] back I'm gonna store all this
hover fuel horror fuel can I hover am
Iron Man
oh look at me go oh that's so cool oh
that's so cool dear I'm asking I'm a
skating alone okay so I need to use the
map probably to actually find something
good cuz there seems to be death all
around me but where I is there is
nothing to help me so somewhere here is
gonna be there's gonna be some sweet
dank something or other
oh it's raining I didn't I think there
would be rain on this desolate planet
whoo geez that sounds bad
something gonna happen something mmm
you know like you that can't see where
I'm going can't see where I'm going so
temperature high which just means I'm
running too much so the map says there's
like a drop-off or something over here
and they would be very correct there is
one hell of a drop-off holy [ __ ]
I don't know if I can survive that I
don't know if I'm supposed to survive
that pretty sure this is supposed to be
a deterrent for me going that way well
[ __ ]
what's that over there whoa what's with
the shadowy figures is that the good or
bad oh my go towards it but the ominous
music seems to be crescendoing from this
direction it is an alien planet and who
knows how how many hostels might be here
oh it's that hmm is that something
carbon whoo okay I'm getting into
resources is that like a forest over
there okay going down in the pit this
doesn't seem like a very safe thing to
do hydrogen geyser that sounds nice okay
good okay I'll get some carbon I'll take
some sweet dank carbon did give us key
okay I got some carbon yeah yeah there
we go okay so where do I see more carbon
over here unlike this goop
god I wish I could see how do I turn on
my goddamn uh how do I turn on my
goddamn flashlight such an idiot I am
your boy Emma there we go okay how much
space I got plenty of space I got 44
carbon which should be good enough for
most of what I need I don't have the
means with which to contain that
hydrogen I don't think yeah hidden it's
not gonna do anything
okay so there's got to be something else
somewhere else guess I could go towards
that forest further that is
looks like a forest something it's such
a bizarre feeling venturing into the
unknown
I mean I love this thing about you know
about games like this especially space
games just because I have no idea what's
out there I have no idea if there's
anything even to threaten me
and yet I'm really really anxious right
now and that's a cool feeling to have
you almost shoot whatever comes out at
me what the hell is that thing
oxygen critical okay I got a camp out
for a bit haven't found any plutonium
I'm never gonna get back to my camp at
this point okay now we're getting close
and it does seem to be some sort of
mushroom force it reminds me of the
mushroom force down in subnautica in the
Zangaro region or whatever it was called
rubber tree Oh rubber it's a rubber tree
it's a whole tree made out of rubber can
I get it hey hey yeah okay I can just
wail on this thing forever let's go get
me all the rubber I need let's go get me
so much rub a rubber takes up nothing
I'll get two stacks Oh No maybe more
might as well
seems like actions are faster in
first-person mode but it's not as
aesthetically please
it's a son gonna come out yet I mean my
god I'm tired of this overcast
dreariness okay how many stacks four
more rubber there we go that's uh two
more there we go
that's a full four stacks okay so now I
just need some gear steering something
or other I guess I should head back
because I don't know where else to go
and this this hovering is kind of nice
because it saves me some energy when I'm
sprinting because I still go the scene
hello oh hey hey hey there is other life
here let's kill it
whoo it's bar is red so I'm pretty sure
that means bad right yeah how about it
how about day how about it soon how
about it whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
Wow whoa whoa wait whoa holy [ __ ]
he exploded alien meat okay yes I am a
threat to your planet
I came here to conquer if you have any
women better hide them I'm climbing in
your windows hide your husbands - well
the music definitely didn't like the
fact that I killed one of their
creatures one of the gentle creatures of
this planet just died now someone seems
unhappy but I'm gonna make my way back
to camp with the resources that I got um
man it says it wants me to complete the
habitat structure so I might do that
first and then maybe it'll give me a
better idea where I can get plutonium
mooo something was down there something
alive
something amongst the carbon I saw
something whoa hey whoa whoa whoa that
looks big whoa whoa Nelly
young crab monster I'm glad that its
name literally says monster cuz I well I
hit it in its brain probably dead young
crab monster raid dead creature no I'm
gonna raid it got that alien meat hmm I
hate these potatoes have evolved past
the need for Peter hood and hungered o
larvae scallop above what was that oh
that don't look good oh jeez
oh god well at least now it's day holy
[ __ ] I can see my god this place is
infested yeah okay where the hell is my
goddamn bass what the hell is Bubble Boy
how did I get lost I know I got lost
everything looks too goddamn same here
geez okay come I oh there's more oh of
course there's more of course there's
more I didn't see any on the way in I
must have crossed over some weird
territory here cuz I'm not in the right
spots
you want to on a go bruh huh you want to
go Oh too bad for you
give me dad alien meat so wasn't over
there it definitely wasn't over there
but this map doesn't look any familiar
and I can't zoom out oh I'm screwed
[Music]
oh I'm so screwed what is that
that looks glowy that's not carbon
that's not carbon that ain't falco
that is copper yes I'll take some copper
hell yeah come at me copper yeah that's
sweet you let's ruin okay god I gotta
gotta gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
okay got the copper mom out here and I
can actually see which is nice so III
the weird thing is I don't even see the
original like stone Peaks that I saw
before I mean it definitely wasn't that
broken one I would have noticed if it
was broken like that Oh get out of the
way no I'm running low on oxygen hey
gotta use my zoomy technique I'm out
here oh now it's night again you telling
me that whole cycle is just because it
was gloomy and rainy oh god damn it I am
unlucky on the getting of light I'll
stop being in that goddamn stance oh
[ __ ] you got you I got one expert I
don't need your body maybe it was over
there maybe it was over that way maybe
that's the way way yeah that might have
been it that that actually seems more
likely because yeah I think I just think
I just wanted a different direction on
the way back cuz I couldn't do anything
okay what about this there didn't seem
to be any yeah does not require
additional ammo so I'm gonna bring out
the good old pistol II pissed okay
nevermind I'm gonna bring out this to
the multi-tool because I don't know what
the multi-tool does at this point
besides probably build now I may use
this because it comes with unlimited
AMRO huh call this the game of not being
able to see [ __ ] ah I'm frustrated I
like it no I like their fact that
there's weather and the day/night cycle
that's really cool don't get me wrong
but I just feel like I'm being unfairly
targeted by this [ __ ] I just want to
make it back to camp so I can [ __ ]
die I see it I see it in the distance I
think I see bubble blood too
yeah there's definitely it maybe it'll
be day by the time I get back okay I'm
finally back in my camp which is nice
but still I I didn't get what I needed I
I don't have my goddamn plutonium search
for minerals to build an airlock oh I
don't have no I don't want to skip these
oh I don't want to skip these I didn't
Oh No
oh I've been skipping missions oh that's
not what I wanted at all oh no oh dang
it
Oh dingus dang oh I I did bad oh I did
bad okay so I've got a problem
I can't build this because I don't have
any plutonium and I don't know where to
get plutonium and it's goddamn perpetual
darkness ah it's been perpetually dark
oh man
and somehow you turn on a flashlight no
he'll turn on a flashlight uh how do I
turn on a flashlight how it's all I want
to know the one thing I can't use to
beat the darkness is a goddamn
flashlight push it all the buttons Oh
I'm [ __ ] bad [ __ ] what the hell did
you come from
oh geez you look terrifying I'd love to
know how to [ __ ] look at ya what
button did I just push what bad batch oh
I don't know what button I push damn it
get it oh now I can see ya
oh now you're looking really bad oh geez
you looks QE okay I'm crouched you
apparently leave oh yeah oh you missed
me oh you're dead okay
Jesus what button did I push it's L Oh
flight l sy
whoa what the [ __ ]
okay so now that I solved that mystery
jeez I'm sorry I thought I pushed every
button I went I pushed all the buttons
oh and now I think dawn is breaking okay
so who I did not accomplish much in this
I know I know that I know that this is a
horrible start to this game but I love
it I don't love my start I love this
game it has a lot of potential here and
I don't know how detailed it is when I'm
looking at the build list it doesn't
seem too complex when I look at the
utilities there's only a few things here
when I look at the furniture you know
I'm not too terribly impressed it seems
like a lot of storage and just basic
survival stuff but that's you know the
reason why this is early access because
it's got the potential the framework hi
god dammit what are you what are you
infant giant oh good it's a small giant
oh thank you bubble but I should have
you following me
okay I'm gonna get in my gonna get in my
goddamn habitat
so I can get away from this and I can do
the suit for each thing use clothes okay
and then save whoa Nelly but there's a
lot of potential the framework here is
for something really impressive it all
depends on what the developer wants to
put in it further to make it even bigger
and better so it's available on Steam
right now and early access I think it
was like 25 bucks but in the next
episode and I am gonna do another one
because I know that I need to redeem
myself for this one I'm gonna do
multiplayer and see who I can join on my
horrifying adventures in space so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you and the next
video holy [ __ ]
[Music]